if you were to experience something but
couldn't understand or express the
experience with words then of course you
wouldn't be able to accurately describe
the experience to other people thus no
one else would ever be able to know what
you experienced if this were true though
would that also mean that neither could
you
ludwig wittgenstein was a 20th century
Austrian British philosopher known for
his uniquely innovative and often
confusing ideas regarding the nature of
language internal experience and the
relationship between them to help
illustrate this relationship Vic and
Stein proposed the following
metaphorical thought experiment in his
primary later book philosophical
investigations in which he suggested
that we imagine a group of people each
person has a box inside each box there
is a thing that everyone calls a beetle
however in the context of this thought
experiment no one is allowed to look
inside anyone elses box every one can
only look inside their own and they're
only allowed to talk about what's inside
their box so the question is can anyone
ever know if anyone else actually has a
beetle in their box and can anyone know
what anyone else's beetle actually looks
like if they do sure everyone can
describe what's in their box but they
can of course only talk using words that
everyone shares and understands
regarding what's in their box which in
this case is beetle
[Music]
according to Vicki Stein though the
thing inside the box cannot be
meaningfully talked about using the word
beetle because no one can ever confirm
what any one means by beetle as a result
the word beetle can only mean the thing
that's in the box but doesn't and can't
necessarily describe the thing that's
actually in anyone's box
Vicki Stein uses this beetle analogy to
suggest that the felt states and
sensations that occur in a person's mind
things like smell pain love happiness
sadness and so on are things that no one
can ever communicate sufficiently enough
to share and reveal their experience of
to others I can never see your beetle
and you can never see mine when we
attempt to think and communicate about
the beetle though the word has to be a
word that everyone understands or can be
taught for the word to have any meaning
according to Vicki Stein and many others
language is entirely social this theory
is known as the private language
argument which proposes that no language
can be understandable if it is solely to
one individual rather language is only
formed through shared use amongst the
community of others thus the sensation
of something might exist exclusively to
oneself but it can never be understood
in terms of language exclusively to
oneself meaning we can never know if
anyone experiences anything the same way
we experience it even if everyone talks
about it with the same words we can only
assume arguably trying to rationalize
communicate and comprehend the mental
experience of a sensation as it actually
is
becomes inconceivable after a certain
point for example one could say that
fresh-cut grass smells good but when
asked what it smells like they would
have to go on to say things like it
smells natural or it smells like the
season of spring if then asked what that
smells like
perhaps if one tried hard enough they
could come up with a few other smells to
compare it to but they would eventually
and inevitably reach the limits of
language there would be a final question
of what it smells like that would have
no answer a sensation beyond words that
no one besides the smeller could know
for sure what is like whereof one cannot
speak thereof one must be silent Vik in
Stine writes when referring to the
notion of
of experience and that which exceeds
language and logical understanding
beyond the suggestions of language and
shared meaning arguably what is most
thought-provoking about all of this is
the notion that we can never know what
it feels like to be anyone else other
than ourselves we can never know what
the world might look taste smell sound
and feel like from outside our own head
we can never verify what anyone else's
color blue looks like or what anyone
else's punch in the arm feels like or
what anyone else's sense of love or
happiness is like we are all locked
inside our minds yelling out to each
other and attempt to find out but never
capable of entering anyone elses to find
out for sure even if the framework
structure and wiring of each of our
brains are mostly identical the
unknowable conscious psychological layer
on top of it all
transmutes the experience of
neurological occurrences into something
abstract distanced enough from the
measurable and communicable to ever know
exactly what any of it is where it comes
from and how it might change in
different heads ultimately no matter any
philosophical stance or scientific
theory it is fair to argue that at a
minimum
no one can or will ever know what it
means to have navigated and experienced
this universe in the way that you have
and will each moment that you experience
a particular sense or image of the world
with your particular conditions of
consciousness is forever yours
exclusively withholding the mystery of
what it means to actually be you for all
of eternity perhaps we all feel an
experience in nearly identical ways or
perhaps we all feel an experience in
very dissimilar ways your version of
blue your sensation of pain your
experience of love could perhaps be its
only version of blue it's only version
of pain and it's only version of love to
ever exist in the entire universe the
point is we don't know because each of
us holds the answer that no one else can
ever access
[Music]
you